this is a production of Cornell
University well it's a real honor to be
here and you know there's some
fascinating connections between South
Florida and Cornell that I want to first
introduce you to before delving into our
topic here and this first photo actually
gives a hint of that this is a scene
from the opening day of Fairchild
tropical Botanic Garden at that time
called Fairchild tropical garden in 1938
and a great figure from Cornell was
there dr. Liberty High Bailey and he's
standing right next to David Fairchild
for whom the garden was named and then
there was Robert Montgomery who was the
impetus behind the founding of a lot of
these gardens in South Florida and they
all were converging in in one place and
I want to share with you some of the
great little passages that I've been
able to unearth from our archives of
what these figures had to say about each
other and the times they were they were
in and so this is Robert Montgomery who
actually provided the funds and the land
for these gardens in South Florida who
was originally from Connecticut and was
a self-taught accountant and tax lawyer
whose hobby was trees and you know he
has a gift for great compelling titles
for books you can see there are 50 years
of Accountancy was his autobiography and
but he had a great understated sense of
sense of humor as well but he was
mentioning how at the opening of the
garden the great figures who got it
started including him mentioned dr.
Bailey first dr. Fairchild some other
great figures here of the botanical
world and at that time and publishing
Rolfe and but he says if you're not
thrilled I'm sorry for you garden so and
this was a photo that David Fairchild
took of dr. Bailey's address at the at
the inauguration of the garden so
there's dr. Bailey there it's pretty
dark but that's that was him and the
23rd of March in 1938 and and these were
some key words that dr. Bailey shared
with assembled crowd there that the
garden was he had a lot of admiration
for David Fairchild who when they went
back long ways to another land-grant
institution Michigan State University
where dr. Bailey studied and where David
Fairchild grew up as his father was
there and and so but and dr. Bailey
wanted this garden not only to be a
great honor to dr. Fairchild and whatnot
but also to be a place for rejuvenation
and to and to study the processes of
nature in the tropics and this was and
dr. Bailey came repeatedly in the latter
years of his life to the annual members
meetings so it was him standing next to
no Montgomery Jennings Robert
Montgomery's wife and down there in
South Florida 1939 the next year and and
then later in 1947
dr. Bailey came with his with his
daughter also had a big role to play
here and I know in me Bailey Hort aureum
yeah so some beautiful words about about
their history together that he was a
little boy at Michigan Agricultural
College back then when he was able to
see dr. Bailey at work when he was only
a little boy and then seven years later
I was able to honor him and have him
speak of the garden that was named after
dr. Fairchild and and so this part was
very just said etc etc from all the
different and accomplishments of dr.
Bailey but you know but he says when he
was reading what he had done there would
have been a shorter task to talk about
what he had not that and and he went on
to talk about the great emotion at that
moments when he was a when if I thought
he was and turned out to be the last
time that dr. Bailey would come to the
garden and he also said that them you
know you know I do not think you can
if I feel the emotion of this moment
there are manses of this event which we
have with us today not only the great
Liberty High Bailey but his world known
and distinguished daughter Ethel Zoe who
has been the life companion and
botanical assistant of her father
through the wonderful years of his
botanical and horticultural explorations
and and he was proud to have lived to
see this moment and proud to introduce
these two great forces plants and then
at the end we don't actually know if he
said all this whoops because at the end
he had this little note said this is
what he wanted to say but you probably
would forget to say something
it's always fun looking at archives
because you get to hear their voices and
and dr. Fairchild visited Cornell in
1938 after the opening of the garden so
these are some photos in our archive
from that visit in June of the of the
Bailey port Orion plantings at that time
some raised beds they had there and
there's an Ethel Zoey working with
another assistance of dr. Bailey's and
in the workroom and a man Liberty High
Bailey also had great admiration for
David Fairchild um don't you know he's
everybody you know it's interesting to
think of how these these figures at that
time were really major public
intellectuals major public you know
people who were interpreting science to
the public whereas today you know we
don't hear as many horticultural figures
who've reached this status and so it was
kind of refreshing to know that there
was a time and hopefully hopefully will
be again they both wrote these very
influential in quite popular books like
this was about some he was reviewing
David Fairchild's and appreciating David
Fairchild exploring for plants his first
book David Ferriero alone only wrote
four books and Bailey wrote many more
and
mentioning how just his enthusiasm and
the way he expressed himself was
something that was very refreshing and
charming and and then the Fairchild
garden has a beautiful part of the
garden that's actually dedicated to dr.
Bailey Bailey palm Glade and like the
Fairchild roat's a very long and
beautiful appreciation of Liberty High
Bailey as part of his effort to raise
support for construction of this which
still is a central part of the garden
and and once again reflecting on on what
he experienced in this little boy on the
campus of him Michigan State
Agricultural College and where he first
experienced horticulture and and
professor Bailey's leather life he
focused a lot on palms which were a big
part of why these gardens in South
Florida came to be because Robert
Montgomery was real palm enthusiast when
he got tired of the winters in the
Northeast he bought a winter home and
started collecting homes and there's a
lot of correspondence between him and
dr. Bailey about which calls to include
in the collection and and then that
turned into a eventually a public garden
and and so they're mentioning that he
was mentioning that this is a reason why
they needed the Center for Palms here in
the tropics in South Florida and this is
the back in the early 40s they when they
were just constructing the Liberty the
Bailey palm Glade and then what it looks
like today so it's grown in quite a bit
since then and it wasn't much the worse
for wear after the hurricane so we have
some more planting to do there and this
is the memorial plaque it's hit the
empty overlook there for the Bailey Palm
Glade and we also have the privilege of
featuring of one of the most spectacular
poems in the world which is named after
dr. Bailey copra nice iya Bailey Jana
the Bailey poem from Cuba and it said as
it gets older it develops this wonderful
that looks like almost like a concrete
pillar and it's a slow-growing poem but
very robust and has this beautifully
geometrical crown that leaves are very
stiff very fan-like
and it's one of the most prized poems
that there is that was definitely I am a
great honor and one of the thing one of
the letters I found between Fairchild
and Bailey was about like what's going
to happen with them after they after
they pass on and others have to take up
the work and in many ways that's what
we're all doing we're carrying on the
work of these great founders of these
institutions and and there's still a lot
of progress being made as as Professor
Bailey predicted to you that the some of
the effort despite the fact that we all
have our own interests and our own foci
we're still bringing things forward and
that brings us to the tropics and which
is where most of the action is in the
plant kingdom and we know that even more
precisely than we did back back in the
days of Fairchild and Bailey that's you
know in basically the entire North
temperate forest area we have about
eleven hundred and sixty-six tree
species but in half a square kilometre
in Borneo you have actually more tree
species berries and and also in Ecuador
about that same same number of tree
species so the tropics are unbelievably
rich compared to the temperate zone so
that's where most of the most of the
plants are and most of the threatened
plants as you would expect are also in
that area where where the plants are and
and David Fairchild wrote quite
poetically about the importance of
understanding exploring the tropics that
he you know he grew up in Michigan up in
the north tempered zone and also spend a
lot of his career in Washington DC
working for the US Department of
Agriculture but got a chance early on to
start traveling through the tropics and
to see that
tropics are where where you find most of
the plants and most of the remarkable
animal diversity so I really can't new
life on earth without knowing the
tropics and and also toward the end of
his life Liberty High Bailey was was
spending more and more time in the
tropics studying poems and this is
showing in the pressing home specimens
in Florida and but this was when he was
he was in his 80s and he was in Trinidad
working with poems and he was talking
about how being there despite the
discomfort extends the boundaries of
life so that because the world is such a
big place in such an incredibly diverse
place to explore in the tropics and so
we have a lot of plant work to explore a
lot of you know there's still most of
those plants in the tropics haven't been
cultivated even many of the useful ones
haven't been brought back yet but there
are challenges because even though there
are lots of things that make working
with plants easier in the modern era
there are some things that make it more
difficult many countries have
implemented a lot of restrictions on
collecting from the wild due to changes
in intellectual property laws and
perspectives worldwide which led to the
Convention on Biological Diversity and
other United Nations conventions and the
fled countries to want to make it harder
to access their biodiversity and we're
becoming more and more aware of
potential risks to ecological concerns
of introduced plants and animals and
some of them we know that have become
problems in various regions of the world
and various concerns about also of the
problems caused by by pests that come
along with plants have led to increasing
complexity of import restrictions and
the US Department of Agriculture for
many years has it basically a innocent
until proven guilty approach with plants
and they are gradually shifting to a
guilty until proven innocent approach so
various generate are being prohibited
from entering
didn't used to be and there's a they put
together all of the current regulations
of the USDA are in one document now you
can find as a PDF fortunately because
it's all it's already over twelve
hundred pages long so it's a it's more
complicated to navigate and ever but
it's still possible to do a lot of work
and so to elaborate a little bit on some
of these challenges of the 21st century
where we're in the period of transition
for most of human heritage for most of
human history plants move pretty freely
worldwide indigenous peoples tended to
bring their useful plants from place to
place like the breadfruit is a famous
example moving across the Pacific people
often brought there useful plant you
know the clutch corn moved into the
Americas from Mexico by the various
indigenous peoples and in most countries
rely on foreign plants for their close
to their food and fiber and other
applications and a most of when
varieties would then be improved and
selected they would be free to be shared
with everyone as starting in the early
80s especially when patenting of genes
and patenting of living things started
to be a big factor that became actually
legal first in the US and then a lot of
the developed world's instead of these
improved varieties being being freely
shared to those countries for example
from which the original germ plasm came
they were now being sold back to those
countries that were being forced to to
abide by the patent regimes of the
developed world's and this led to to
those countries restricting access not
wanting their germ plasm to be moved out
of their country and then freely and
then being sold back to them that was
understandably seen as as as what's
called bio piracy and and so this is a
good little summary of the state of
things by a wonderful international
lawyer sabrina Safran who negotiated
some of these trees on behalf of the
united state
and has done written probably the best
articles explaining how things have
changed and how they might change in the
future that basically we have moved from
a plate from this world where where are
things where was basically a commons
free a freely available genetic
resources weren't the property of
governments they weren't the property of
corporations and now we have not only
governments and corporations but also of
often many times indigenous peoples are
also claiming claiming ownership of
their genetic resources to in hopes that
they won't get they won't get taken by
these other entities so and then those
of us who are working with plants for
horticulture with plants for for basic
scientific research often get caught in
the middle of these forces that are
still still being worked out today so
that's something that's still in
progress and we'll talk a little bit
more about that later but I want to
mention the another of the big factors
that's change in our perception and how
we deal with plants is the issue of
invasive species the issue of native
versus non-native species and much of
this debate hinges on philosophy as much
as science and values because a lot of
public policy issues that interface with
science or issues of value as much as
they are of actual data but we a few
years ago we did a little study to try
to try to actually include some data in
consideration of this issue we looked at
plants that the fairchild garden had
distributed as part of its plant sales
and distributions in the early days
before from 1955 to 1979 i was before
there was a much concern about
non-native plants and invasive plants
and we matched them with ex situ
conservation species that had come into
the garden since then plants that in
nature were more restricted and were
brought in for other purposes besides
just bigger in cultivation and
interesting enough
found that there certainly were some
differences that in this if we'd use
this system called the Australian weed
risk assessment system which you can
adapt to different regions which uses a
you score a bunch of different variables
like how prolific it is you know whether
how widespread it is in nature how its
seeds are dispersed whatnot with
environments it grows in and it's a way
to integrate all that information into a
risk assessment and and so basically
there are several categories there's
accept which is the clear area here and
then there's evaluate further meaning
there's not enough there's some concern
but there's not enough information and
then there's reject and of all the
species we evaluated there was only one
of those horticultural introductions
that was in the reject category there
were more that we're in the evaluate
category and the conservation species
there was only one that was in
evaluation category so it wasn't there
weren't a lot of these plants falling
into a high-risk category and in fact
even those that were in the evaluate
category were just just barely above
zero which is the cutoff so whereas the
conservation species were well below so
generally we the the risk didn't look to
be all that great although there are
certainly of the thousands of species
that have been introduced into the u.s.
a few have become problems some of them
here of course and some of them in the
more tropical areas but I think it's
important to keep it and put it in
context and we need to be aware of that
some species will pose a risk but that
most don't and and so I think that's a
good baseline to to use for starting to
evaluate whether plants whether you know
how we we interface with non-native
species and there's also the danger of
guilt by association that sometimes
people we have some of the earliest
introductions of a given family are
given genus was usually easiest to grow
and so that was most likely to be a
problem and then all other members of
that group and it tend to be looked down
on later and such as the Australian
Pines the cassia Ryan is in Florida are
considered quite quite aggressive and
they certainly score very high on the
Australian weed risk assessment but then
in the same family but
looks fairly similar gymnast Toma which
I collage eclis is very very different
though it's a very close relative of the
kazarina's that scores a low risk and
it's been whining for fifty years and
hasn't been a problem and I think that's
a good baseline if it's in Hawaii for a
long time and hasn't spread because just
by any plant can find a niche in Hawaii
that it likes so but once again if we
were to just kind of say well all the
plants in this family must be bad
because when genus was bad we would be
writing off a lot of beautiful plants
and very that aren't a risk but despite
you know some of these challenges that
complicate plant introduction there's a
there are some factors in the modern
world that make plants introduction
actually facilitated and such as the
rapidity of transportation is even you
know fifty years ago it was much harder
to move plants quickly and you know when
you taking cuttings or old plants how
long they spend in a dark box or on a
ship or on a cargo hold of a plane and
what temperature the cargo hold of the
plane is those are all big limitations
on what on how much success you will
have and the exchange of botanical and
horticultural information is just risen
exponentially so now people can learn
about what plants might be promising for
food what might be promising for as
beautiful plants or what plants might be
even risky as invasive all that
information is so much more rapidly
available now we can really collaborate
with people overseas so much more easily
and that and that's facilitated things
quite a bit and and there is a growing
interest in in tropical plant diversity
especially in Asia there's a there's a
Thailand has just exploded in the last
15 20 years with interest you know there
are small nurseries going all kinds of
amazing plants there China has become
actually a great great economic engine
for a lot of that horticultural activity
in Thailand and elsewhere because
there's so much demand now as the
economy has improved there and there's a
lot of appreciation for the beauty of
tropical plants same in Japan and
and in the certain segments of even in
the u.s. there's increasing interest for
example and the world of air rights we
just had a big arrow I'd show at
Fairchild Garden and we everybody was
coming at how many young people were
there because they're now popular
houseplants and people are getting
excited about all the different types
that can be available and can be grown
and and the horticulture fortunately
provides a way to work with the changing
international regime of accessing plant
genetic resources because many countries
view horticulture very differently than
maybe you going directly to the wild and
collecting something for a scientific
project because some countries are
fostering the development of their own
horticultural industries and may of
course want them to be able to sell
plants overseas and they see that the
benefits of that coming back to their
countries in the form of money which is
easiest benefit to see and countries
like Ecuador where be very difficult
it's often very challenging you get
permits to do anything that requires
bringing plants back but if you work
with nurseries there they can bring a
wonderful new plants into cultivation
and that can then be freely shared and
for the for the benefit enjoyment of all
and that's happening in many many
countries because it's a way that
countries seed benefits from their
biodiversity coming back to their
country and we can benefit by enjoying
those plants in horticulture and and
that's that's pretty encouraging and in
countries like Thailand especially are
showing just the tremendous potential of
that we're huge economic sectors of the
economy are are being built on this and
basically the plant biodiversity and
enjoyment of it and
and another another aspect that's
becoming at least more appreciated in
the Botanical Garden world and is
starting to actually be appreciated
internationally is that introduction of
new plants can sometimes save species
and save genetic diversity because
sometimes there's a growing number of
cases where one person or one
institution just with interest in
growing a plant that's endangered or
rare in the wild has saved that plant
and that plant could then be repatriated
to the country of origin showing that
you know the planted reduction effort
can have you know huge huge conservation
benefits and plants that are now very
very rare in the wild as when people are
now with an advent of genetic technology
for looking at population genetics have
been discovering that some of these old
garden collections have alleles that are
now no longer far out in the wild
population there's a point interesting
recent case is the double coconut and
the world produces the world's largest
seed and they're old collections in the
same port in the Singapore Botanic
Garden that were introduced in the 30s
and when they started doing population
genetics I found the quite a few alleles
in that and those cultivated plants that
aren't found in the Seychelles where
it's needed anymore so it's been able to
extend the genetic conservation of that
species and some very very rare species
are able to be backed up in cultivation
the entire you know all their genetic
diversity because you can take cuttings
from all the extant plants and grow them
in a fairly small face in a greenhouse
and you know make sure that however
whatever happens with the pressures on
the native environment there will least
be a backup of that genetic diversity
that can be returned once things
stabilized in situ and and we certainly
need more diversity in the world of food
and ornamental plants and just plants
are appreciated for their wonder because
despite all the advances in agriculture
and horticulture in the last century
we've still only 12 crops or supplying
80% of the world's food and when we have
30,000 species that are known to be
edible and that's just with other
plants that doesn't include medicinal
plants and all the other and this is an
example at fair trial we have a major
program of mango diversity and we have
over 300 mango cultivars at San offsites
garden that we have and each July we
feature this tremendous cultivar
diversity all the flavors and textures
when most people experience mangos
especially in temperate climates they
you know they're they're just having one
usually one cultivar that ships well has
a lot of fiber in it it's not nowhere
near as nice as a mango can be and
whereas the the potential for this fruit
is tremendous and then their main fruits
whose potential has been far less
explored than the mango and and one that
one of the places where this some
there's been an interface between
conservation and and food has been the
breadfruit Institute at the National
Tropical Botanic Garden Hawaii and this
is an example of where one person dr.
Diana Oni who did their PhD on
breadfruit in the Pacific back in the
late 80s
she went throughout the Pacific and
collected fruits from the different
islands and brought them back to the
National tropical Botanic Garden and in
the succeeding years
there are many of those islands where
they're as they're the cultures are
going through urbanization and different
economic changes they would lose their
their their native breadfruit cultivars
that had been developed on their
individual islands but many of those
were saved at the breadfruit Institute
and be returned to those islands and
also made available or feeding hungry
people throughout the tropics and now a
tissue culturing several new varieties
each year and just making them freely
available to countries in the world that
that are interested in this very
nutritious and low-maintenance food that
we're you which you can grow just by
anywhere where there isn't where there
isn't frost or cold weather and and some
other really great examples of how
horticulture can actually save species
through their just some enthusiasm and
through sometimes moving the plants
around out of there out of where they
were native this is actually this is a
hibiscus relative in Hawaii that just
thanks to a few people who decided to
graph it
um it's not not in danger of extinction
there's only a few genotypes left but it
was just down to one tree several and
several times several occasions and if
they hadn't brought it to the Botanic
Gardens it would be extinct and one of
the few modern horticulturists to make
it to celebrity status good friend of
mine Carlos Magdalena have two gardens
has become a bit you know a bit of a
celebrity by saving some really
prominent plants from extinction plants
that were sometimes called the Living
Dead where they're down to one
individual and they can't propagate it
they may have a disease that's flowing
down its metabolism like this is which
was the case with this beautiful coffee
relative ramos-montigny Rodrigue SEI
which is endemic to the island of
mauritius and he kept trying to torture
different different individuals of this
plant that it would not set seed on its
own and there was only one clone left
and eventually growing one you know in a
certain way that was a little stressful
he got one one seed to develop a viable
embryo and the germinate and then he
could cross that seedling with
appearance and because he just would not
give up on this beautiful rare plant it
wasn't because he had tremendous
resources behind him to do this a lot of
staff to help him it was because he
cared and that's I think a very
empowering message about plant
conservation is that even though in in
many cases hard to influence governments
it's hard to influence international
trends but one person can make a
difference for a species and I think
that's a that's a beautiful aspect of
horticulture that we need to talk about
more and a recent example of this even
more recent is I just happened in the
wake of Hurricane Maria which struck
Berto Rico um late last year and they
got hit much harder than we did in South
Florida we had the edge of Hurricane
Emma and but Hurricane Maria was just
devastated Puerto Rico and one of its
endemic potato and tomato relatives so
let's align them and so folium was down
to just a few individuals that were left
at a few sites and after the
storm none of those could be found again
they seemed all been destroyed and a
graduate student who was working on the
endemic Solanaceae enrico was able to
just search online and find out of all
places the University of Connecticut
their wonderful research collection and
teaching collection they had two clones
addressed that had been grown at
Fairchild Garden up until the mid-2000s
it was probably Hurricane Wilma that did
those plants him but fortunately a
student who'd been studying them from
the Northeast took cuttings Scott
brought them up to Connecticut and they
were maintained there at the teaching
collection and as far as we know these
two individuals are the last of the
species and it was just because a couple
people decided to propagate it it's
going to be around to hopefully
repatriate to Frederico we of course we
all hope it'll reappear in Puerto Rico
so that there will be more diversity but
at least we have a couple of individuals
or their cuttings from wild
well plants and this is one that was
just sent back down to Fairchild from
the University you know they can so now
that we know how important this is we're
trying to get it spread as far as we can
to make sure that it's um it won't be
lost to posterity and to nature and lest
you think that this is that these are
just you know isolated anecdotes if we
look at the best documented cases of
extinction and an extinction in the wild
where it also exists in horticulture um
based on the IUCN Red List they've
documented a hundred one plant species
extinct you know many more are extinct
they're mainly extinct that we'll never
know that they existed but this is the
old these are the only hard numbers we
really have now and but but in addition
there are 35 species they're extinct in
a while but survived in cultivation so
without horticulture that means there'd
be 29 percent higher extinction rate for
plants
whereas if animals the same figures are
less than five percent plants are have a
lot of advantages you can take cuttings
you know of them so you can clone them
very easily they don't need a lot of
space you know you can grow a tremendous
amount of diversity in a small space
they're the most you know
exchangable they're easy to send long
distances so we can we can do a lot more
with plants and the potential to
conserve them through horticulture is
pretty impressive and this is not
through any concerted effort this is
just through a disorganized group of
gardeners Botanic Gardens and
universities across the world doing this
imagine what could be done if we
actually put our minds to it and
coordinated so as a Botanic Garden we
introduce plants from from a variety of
sources I'm going to give a couple
examples of how that's done in the
modern era we do the traditional way
which is while collecting expeditions
also exchanging with other botanic
gardens commercial nurseries and private
collectors those are the main sources
and they go to to a gardens nursery
where we do our first stage of
evaluation trying to keep them alive
keep the proper gills alive and seeing
how easy they are to propagate and and
then there are all kinds of uses in a
modern botanical garden and in other
botanical institutions that they may be
used for education research beauty
conservation and evaluation for the
broader use in horticulture and so while
collecting expeditions as I mentioned
they're harder they're getting harder
all the time in most countries and even
if you're allowed to collect many times
they want to make agreements that are
very restrictive with regard to what can
later be done with those plants so you
need to in this new area you need to
carefully negotiate to make sure that
everybody's interests are respected and
and so in some countries we've had a
little more latitude to collect than
others we have it we have a great
relationship with garden there and we
made a couple of expeditions there in
2012 and 2013 and this is what just you
know like client collecting was in the
old days we're going out and collecting
cuttings and seeds and using interesting
conveyances and sometimes it was a
pickup truck and there's no room for the
most elegant things we just pile them on
top of ourselves and bring them back and
get them inspected for for pests in the
country of origin and packed up very
carefully and brought back labeled
accessions and hopefully they'll survive
and one of the are successful
introductions was this is clevy of
doming dentists which is endemic to
haiti which is a lot of conservation
struggles in the modern era it's about
98 percent deforested and this is a
species that's founded just a handful of
individuals it's a very beautiful
ornamental and and the Botanic Garden
the Dominican Republic has been
propagating it for a number of years
from early collections they made and
they've been sharing propagations with
other gardens throughout the world and
now we have a number of those we have
about 10 individuals growing Fairchild
and we think they'll flower flowers soon
and that we've been working with the
Botanic Garden he needs to make more
wild collections from the handful of
remaining individuals to make sure we
conserve as much genetic diversity as
possible and we worked with our partners
there to make the first successful
horticultural introduction of a special
plumeria species plumeria Magnum one of
the biggest fragile pennies there is it
can get to be 90 feet tall and and the
Botanic Garden there had not been
successful in grafting or grafting them
or propagating them from cuttings so we
we've had success now and we're going to
be bringing them back on our next trip
to the Botanic Garden there so they'll
be able to use them in plantings in the
Dominican Republic where its native
we've had some Nitze follow-up
opportunities on some of the things that
David Fairchild dreamed about possible
in his time but they're possible now we
have trouble in the in the deep tropics
growing the Mediterranean fig because we
have trouble with humidity and heat
there it's um you get a rust fungus they
get nematodes and there's this Sun
several tropical figs that are edible
but most figs require their pollinator
wasps to ripen and and be palatable and
certainly true of this this is the
Roxburgh fig ficus auricular sometimes
called the coconut feet and but there
are a few clones that actually are what
I'll personal
perfect like the banana where they will
like our common Cavendish banana where
the fruit will ripen without being
fertilized so there aren't and without
producing viable seeds and it turns out
that one of our neighboring Gardens had
inadvertently introduced one of these
collecting plants after Hurricane in
Indonesia one clone they brought back if
this species turns out to be part no
carpet and we've been propagating at
David Fairchild he wrote a whole article
when when does anyone gonna do something
about the great figure of the Himalayas
you know and here the plants at his home
at the Kampong he spent years using all
these tricks like olive oil to slather
the fruit and trying to make it ripen it
never worked and now we fortunately have
one the one that he would have wanted
and similarly he was very keen on the
potential of the sycamore fig of the
Middle East and in Africa which is a fig
that thrives vegetatively in South
Florida and in tropical climates but
also generally requires its pollinator
wasps but there's a variety that rose in
the Middle East about sixteen hundred
years ago that will ripen without
pollination called Bellamy and collector
in South Florida worked about thirty
years to get this into cultivation and
finally did and shared cuttings with us
and they've made fruits that are quite
tasty so david fairchild also was trying
for years with this species he had a one
of the typical form at his home and one
of the traditional ways of making these
ripe and going back to antiquity was to
cut the small the figs when they were
very very tiny which would stimulate
ethylene production and make them ripen
so he had to cut individually each of
the figs and he could never get the
stage just right and so he never
succeeded in but now we have the one
that you don't need to do anything we'll
just write them and we're also
introducing plants that are important
conservation value some of which
required the collaboration of several
institutions to make a successful
introduction this is a important conifer
from new caledonia our acharya muller i
this is kind of from new caledonia is
this lost world in the south pacific
with 4746
I guess 47 now endemic conifer species
in the tropics
now the place we usually associate with
conifers but Congress happen to be one
of the most endangered plant groups in
the world about 34% of them are
considered threatened or endangered so
that's an important group to be backing
up in different collections and so this
was shared with with us by the Royal
Botanic Gardens Edinboro and then our
colleagues at the University of Florida
that managed to graft it on to a
rootstock that's much better for our
soils but it's too cold up there to grow
this outside year-round so they gave us
this grafted individual to plants in the
garden now so our three institutions has
finally made this and some horticultural
expertise has made this possible to get
this conserved xc2 and increasingly
we're going through this route of
horticulture for plant introductions and
in Thailand is the epicenter for
tropical horticulture and so we're we're
going increasingly ever just every
December to the biggest plant show in
Southeast Asia the Rama nine plants show
and sale we're basically anybody who's
in the botanical world and horticultural
world in Southeast Asia tries to get to
this and you get probably about nearly a
hundred vendors in this giant circle in
this big part in Bangkok and just you
just it's overwhelming what you'll find
there all the amazing plants and
individual nurseries specializing in
plants of this family and an AC
specialize in Podocarpus specializing
this this the diversity is just
fantastic and each time we go around
we'll go around the first time and find
a whole bunch of things and they go well
we've got a few things we still need to
find the next day and we go around it's
not a few things it's still just as many
and then the next day we find even more
and so it's just it's pretty
overwhelming like what we can find and
what's available now and also in the
various local nurseries in Thailand that
are introducing all kinds of wonderful
new things to cultivation this is [ __ ]
sock who's a legendary collector from
from that area and to many things in
this very favorable climate they're able
to just use clear plastic bags to
cuttings and grow things from leaf
cuttings and graft and Thailand they
graph so many things it's amazing
their master graph drafters there and we
can find nurseries with row after row of
amazingly grown epiphytic like a pots
which is a pretty amazing thing to see
and and just that these are now all
available and as beautiful specimens
that can be shipped to the US is pretty
pretty amazing and so fortunately our
Thailand is set up for for horticultural
introductions so everything is very very
efficient there we have a good friend
and colleague who comes to Miami several
times home SAP OC reach lvanych
and he he's able to get this all air
freight into Miami in about a day and a
half and so they agree of all the
phytosanitary documents we go through
all the regulations and you know we're
still able to get about eighty percent
success this way sometimes even higher
depending on the type of plant and so
last December we we brought back 22 big
boxes of new plants this way and they
keep out of it as well the opportunities
exist and we also even have a growing
network of exchange with botanical
institutions overseas as well this was a
botanic garden north of Bangkok that
gave us several of their endemic plants
trees of limestone areas around there
which we have very similar substrates in
Miami where we're a lot of limestone and
they were able to give us an entire
genus Santa zukie oh there are two
species and they gave us both of them so
it's nice to be able to complete
collections and you know just like in
the old days plants collecting can be
pretty messy this is a little apartment
in singapore botanic garden where they
let me stay they let me stay even after
i've done this multiple times and filled
everything up with plants and then
brought him back in my and my luggage
after they get get inspected and we get
them back to the garden and and you know
even after a very rigorous trip you know
then the work has just begun we have to
get all of these settles posit up with
under mist or fog and and try to get
them into a favorable microclimates and
see if we can get most of them to
succeed
and sometimes we even find plants that
are they're very useful that are that
are new fruits like this is sand or acum
which is a very fluffy fruit that they
have all these new different cultivars
in the entire island of it but some of
these many of these plants we just bring
back because they're wonderful and one
person who was influenced by Liberty
High Bailey was Wendell Berry and I
think is what he said about twenty years
ago that that if we don't learn to value
things for just for being wonderful in
of themselves we're going to lose a lot
of them because a lot of current
approach to conservation and whatnot
tends to be what is what are things
useful for are they useful for they can
be useful for medicine food or carbon
storage or something but the problem is
that all those things may come and go
but we still need this biodiversity for
the future and we need to figure out how
to appreciate it for how wonderful it is
and one plant that I've gotten extremely
interested in it's like its deltoid here
which comes in all these amazing local
it's an epiphytic fig in Southeast Asia
that comes in all these local reforms
and different habitats and they're all
part of the same species but they're
they're all genetically distinct and you
see some of their big leaves some of the
small big big small figs and a wonderful
example of just evolution in action and
that you can demonstrate by you know
just growing a whole diverse range of
this individual species in the tropics
and you introduce some very other
promising ornamentals like this
beautiful gorilla that as bold and leaf
undersides most ravillious
and the pro tac family don't do well in
South Florida they don't like our high
pH soils but we discovered we saw this
growing in several places in Southeast
Asian said let's try it and it's turned
out to be remarkably adaptable and it's
not sensitive the phosphorus like many
of them are even they're going so so low
as to as two or so high as to appreciate
bryophytes and this is a liverworts
brought back a couple years ago that's
got this beautiful central black portion
that illustrates its like how the mist
branching and that's caused a bit of a
sensation among my growing with our
community and Sailaja Nellas even this
is what I call a gateway Sailaja nella
so those of you who haven't gotten
bitten by this incredibly diverse Lika
fide group this is salah janela picta
from vietnam it's a recent introduction
to horticulture and now that's a in
Thailand it's being propagated widely
but it has its central leaves turn
whites very early in development so it
has this natural variation that's quite
striking and it's not that hard to grow
and another it this is a beaut
beautifully primeval endangered Sailaja
nama species from the Philippines that's
just entered horticulture and there's
actually endangered in the wild but
they've been but it's actually not that
hard to grow and it's just gorgeous it
looks like it's made of plastic and came
right at leas oh except as I mentioned
many exchanges with Botanic Gardens this
is from a new species from the Solomon
Islands a Podocarpus from the Royal
Botanic Gardens Edinboro that it's new
we've look as pretty as any flower so
and a lot of wonderful poems that are
coming into horticulture that are just
you know on the level of a Bailey's
wonderful poem and they're wonderful
geometry some plants that look like
poems of it aren't poems this is a
cyclin from the Americas and this is a
group of plants that has tremendous
horticultural potential that's actually
more appreciated in Asia than it is in
the new world for their for their
tremendous diversity and beauty and
they're actually more closely related to
the pan downs and to the palms
but where we're introducing a lot more
of these and evaluating how they do in
horticulture some of the beautiful
plants from Mauritius this like this
plant that is these beautiful shiny
small leaves look like oak leaves that
we brought back from a collection in
Thailand that's never been grown and in
the u.s. before but looks very very
promising easy to propagate we never get
tired of iridescent blue plants this is
a sedge from Southeast Asia you know if
you thought that sedges were just little
nondescript green things in the in the
swamps this is a in the Trop
say they can become really spectacular
this one has this special kind of
iridescent based on the different layers
of silica on its leaves and gets the
shiny blue color in the in the shady
areas and this is a cool ago a poem
grass which is a Nepal more grass type
sweet heaven horticulture have been a
pretty bland green but this is a wild
species from Southeast Asia
and nobody had has it in horticulture
until very recently so there's so much
potential out there so much to explore
it's pretty exciting in the tropics and
like this potato and tomato relative of
solanum it feels like velvet just really
densely velvety leaves from Ecuador
that's got into some collections through
the Ecuadorian nurseries and now you can
find in the toilet they're enjoying it
there as well and this is a brand new
introduction to North American
horticultural med NOAA that when we
first just tired in the conservatory a
Fairchild a couple of weeks ago and the
Sun came through its leaves which are
red in the back we saw this amazing
effect where the red blending into the
green you know gives this just a
wonderful kind of orange II red glow to
it so which no one else who's grown this
genus before is seen so you know we
never know what we're going to discover
when we introduce these wonders these
new wonders yeah it hasn't flowered yet
but some med nillas have pendulous
flowers some of them have flowers on the
stem so there's all different some are
more showy than others so we're know
now that's action
just the effect of the Sun line shining
through the red backs of the leaves so
it's actually it's basically green on
the top and red underneath so it's yeah
it's yeah in Thailand they're really
into variegated plants so I'm not even
going there right now that would be that
would be many lectures on the science of
irrigation in Thailand and I don't want
to leave out some flowers even though
I'm a big fan of foliage but this is a
beautiful and an AC of area that has
this mysterious resin that it produces
in the middle of its flowers but it's
pretty spectacular and it also makes
notable fruit so it's not only gorgeous
but edible and there's also some active
breeding going on in Southeast Asia and
a lot of popular plant groups and this
is one of the most exciting new triumphs
of a wonderful horticulturist in
Indonesia this is your sina stardust JT
stardust and it's a hybrid between one
Bornean species that keeps its spots all
its life but is pretty diminutive and
one that has big beautiful strap-like
leaves but has spots early on but then
loses them when it matures so this one
has the big strap-like leaves and it
keeps it spots so it's a really example
of the best of both species for
ornamental uses and and I'd like to end
with ajust a couple of reflections from
David Fairchild here and even though he
had a very illustrious career in many
ways but in the end it came down as his
philosophy at the end of his life was it
was really all about the plants that you
know all the things he did all the
things he wrote and whatnot but he said
that what what was more important to him
were the trees and at his home at the
Camco and all the wonders that were
associated with them so he had really
you know he was certainly even though
he'd focused a lot on useful plants on
plants being important to enrich us food
and and us ornament but he just loved
the plants in and of themselves and and
this was sometimes called his last
Testament here that he wrote after his
last big expedition right before World
War two to Southeast Asia
but what one collects in the shape of
opinions data facts and figures have a
rather small chance of being passed on
to others and doing some good and some
of that you know it superseded as we
know but he saw that you know
introducing some seeds and plants that
may be passed on to someone in the
future and grown by them selected by
them just appreciated have a good chance
of doing something good to people long
after the shadows fall and and his other
aspect of whether he hopes that our
gardens would do is to be places of
wonder and and to in some way change the
world and I know that Cornell University
is at the forefront of that kind of
activity and I hope you can all work
together to to further this this vision
of making the world a greener and and
friendlier place for humans and plants
and and just for the wonders of nature
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu